[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the last bonus show of the
year no i'm kidding pat's looking
confused uh it's not we've still got
like a whole month left to go so don't
don't don't worry about that
everything's fine
um pat
quickly looking for a calendar on the
wall
um okay hey this is very interesting
there's a piece in the week by ryan
cooper
which points out that joe biden has
dramatically
scaled back drone strikes and for years
remember that under barack obama there
was a whole bunch of yeah obama's okay
but the drone stuff is terrible
and then under donald trump even though
donald trump insisted that he was going
to be the guy not to start new wars he
did a lot of droning in fact and
very quietly without much fanfare
joe biden has dramatically scaled back
drone strikes and it's not getting a lot
of attention the um a possibility of air
strikes retaliating
for certain elements early during
biden's presidency was a topic but it's
quite interesting that it's basically
not a story
yeah i mean there was that one drone
strike that biden ordered which did get
a lot of attention which was the
response to the isis k attack at the
airport when the u.s was pulling troops
out of afghanistan so and that turned
out to be botched i think it was uh all
civilians that they killed 10 civilians
something like that many of them
children and so you know maybe it's in
response to that disaster that they've
they've decided to scale this back a
little bit and maybe it's because of
that that we're not even hearing
much about the decision to scale it back
at all like they don't want to continue
the negative press coverage that they
got from that botched attack right and
they may figure that well if we decide
to announce to the public that we're
going to scale down drone strikes then
we're sort of admitting that that was a
mistake to have done that in the first
place but it does in some respects feel
like a missed opportunity to be doing
this and not to mention it because i'd
have to imagine that there are a good
amount of people especially on the left
who want to cut down the number of drone
strikes that we're doing and to do it
without announcing it that just seems
like a wasted opportunity questionable
legal infrastructure for many of these
drone strikes
very questionable moral underpinnings
you would think that it's something they
shouldn't be silent on and i'm actually
encouraged because of this article which
pat pat found this article for for
today's bonus show i the article has
convinced me that we should not be
silent about the fact that there has
been this big scale back and so next
week i'm gonna i'm gonna do the story
with additional information on on the
regular show because i it should be
discussed and hey you know what if
people don't like it let them come out
and say no we should be droning more
people right put them in the position of
having to say that
yeah that often happens we'll we'll test
out a show a story on the bonus show
right and then if it goes well then
we'll decide okay this is worthy of the
main show
on the main show and that's exactly what
we're doing here testing the waters sure
but yeah i mean i think they should make
a big deal out of this i suppose we
really want to take a look at how the
american public feels when it comes to
drone strikes and if there really is
this widespread support against
continuing them because in theory you'd
think that people would be in support of
them because the idea is okay well you
can you can take out targets uh take out
the enemy without putting american
troops in danger because you're not
putting boots on the ground you just
order these attacks from the sky and so
there's really no risk for us but a
higher reward in practice it turns out
to not always be that way because of
course we often don't get the best
intelligence sometimes we kill the wrong
people sometimes the attacks miss or
even worse like we kill the first
responders like we saw from you know uh
leaked tapes and that sort of thing in
the past um and so you know it's one of
those things where like maybe the public
just doesn't know too much about it and
they think okay well the alternative is
just going to be we're going to put
american troops in danger and we don't
like that either so maybe that would be
something that could backfire against
biden it would make it look like maybe
he's not so pro-military at all that
he's actually going to be putting troops
at risk that's exactly the thought
process but then the question is
is biden putting troops on the ground
instead and the answer is no it's not
that this is like an old conventional
wisdom which is
sometimes people are mad about drone
strikes because they're like
we don't like the idea of drone strikes
instead of nothing
and then often accurately we say well
often times it's drone strikes instead
of boots on the ground in this case
biden is scaling back drone strikes but
he's not doing boots on the ground
yeah totally and he pulled out of
afghanistan you got to give him credit
for that i mean there's a number of
issues especially when it comes to
foreign policy that certain sectors of
the right really should be giving him
credit for i'm not talking about the
neocon right sure but those those sort
of like libertarian
non-interventionalist right-wingers they
should be very very happy with what
biden has done so far for sure when it
comes to foreign policy but of course
they're staying hush-hush and they're
just finding different ways to criticize
him because ultimately i don't know if
they're really all that policy oriented
it's more about trying to give wins to
trump and republicans and that sort of
thing it's not about whether or not he's
actually pulling troops out of the
middle east when bush liked the iraq war
it was good and then when trump said it
was bad and wars are bad then they were
bad but then
now that it's by not getting us into
wars at least so far they don't care
about it anymore it's the same old thing
as far as as far as that goes so we'll
talk more about that next week when i do
a full story on it
right now there is a major fight over
the future of abortion at the supreme
court as many of you know roe v wade is
the 1973 decision that as a general rule
legalized abortion in the united states
still subject to state regulation
sometimes states go too far and courts
will say this
implicitly violates roe v wade right now
the supreme court is hearing a case
dobbs the jackson women's health
organization
this is the mississippi law
that bans abortion after 15 weeks of
pregnancy
and over time
the court has always
upheld roe v wade
the central framework of it by rejecting
significant infringement on abortion
rights the idea is constitutionally
women have a right to an abortion during
the first two trimesters of pregnancy
when the fetus would be unable to
survive outside of the womb that's about
24 weeks
mississippi has asked the supreme court
not only
to find in their favor here but also to
reverse prior abortion decisions and to
simply say
states can decide now
i think it's fair to say pat
at most times since 1973 we would have
said
this has no chance this is not going to
happen
but we now have neil gorsuch on the
court we have brett kavanaugh we have
amy covid barrett as she is known in
some circles trump appointees
and although we don't know what's going
to happen there are legal experts who
are saying they are sending some signals
that they're at least willing to side
with the anti-abortion side here but we
don't know if they all will they all
might but we don't know that they all
will
this would be a massive blow to abortion
rights in the united states
absolutely and we won't know for sure
what they decide to rule until june but
i am definitely worried we know that
supreme court justices and judges in
general try to
not buck the precedent so the idea is
well if roe versus wade have has been on
the books for 50 years or so then maybe
there's going to be this call to not
overturn it but we also know that these
judges are ideological and they may say
well 50 years in the grand scope of
things that's not that long and
ultimately if they're conservative they
want to reduce abortion rights to begin
with and so they may decide to side with
mississippi here and ultimately
ultimately we will see what happens
because you know we don't really have
that much of a say in what's going on
here they clearly have the majority and
they can certainly do this if they want
to i mean i'd imagine that conservatives
will argue that it's not going to be the
end of the world and women will still be
able to get abortions they'll just have
to go to states that are more
left-leaning and you know if you're in
need of an abortion and if you're in a
red state like mississippi well that's
okay you can just take a greyhound bus
up to you know illinois or somewhere
like that after 15 weeks
yeah
yeah and so they'll act as if it's not
the end of the world and it's not that
draconian or restrictive or anything
like that but we know the reality of
this stuff you know we know it's not
always so easy to get that greyhound bus
or to take off work or to have
permission from your parents in some
cases when you're talking about uh women
who are under 18 girls uh so yeah like
in and there's this talk about well you
know is 15 weeks is why is that not
enough time oftentimes 15 weeks it's
just around the cusp of when you find
out that you're pregnant uh and so it's
it's definitely one of those things
where you do need more time and that's
why i think the viability metric of
about 22 to 24 weeks makes a lot more
sense to me and that should remain the
law yeah and for people who are gonna
say
listen people know they're pregnant
before that that time you would have
multiple missed periods or whatever you
you
sometimes periods are irregular
sometimes different things happen
there's not always a physical change up
until you know 14 15 so it's not quite
so clear and the big picture is that our
worst fears about the entire trump
disaster were true we said in 2016 i
mean think back pat we said in 2016
hillary is no progressive beacon okay
but if trump wins and he gets two maybe
three supreme court picks
it could be a disaster including the end
of abortion as we know it in the united
states and there were some people
including people supposedly on the left
saying no that's not going to happen and
that's not a big enough deal and no no
no no no
it all happened trump got his three
supreme court picks we said they're
going to keep doing this at the state
level appeal appeal appeal until
eventually the supreme court takes one
and maybe does something to reverse
president president on roe v wade
we might be six months from that i mean
we're it it all is potentially happening
yep and that's why sometimes you just
gotta suck it up and vote for the lesser
of two evils if you perceive both uh
parties to be evil if you perceive both
candidates to be evil well then make
sure that you employ harm reduction and
that's the view that noam chomsky and
plenty of others have taken and
certainly that's the side that i was on
that's the side that you were on yeah
and um yeah i mean this is definitely
the consequence it is still pretty
shocking though that he was able to get
three supreme court justices i mean we
knew that he was going to get at least
one right but the fact that he that he
got three when obama before him only got
two he was supposed to get three but um
you know obviously the republicans in
the senate blocked him but that took him
eight years where trump was able to do
it in four years uh get three justices
on the court so yeah i mean a lot of
this stuff was predictable and what can
we do at this point you can try to have
the best lawyers argue in favor of
abortion rights but you're trying to
appeal to these conservative justices
and you just gotta cross your fingers
and pray i guess you know how trump says
about the pandemic it never should have
happened this never should have happened
all you can do now is get the best
lawyers as you say pat but it never
should have happened hillary clinton
should have won and of course i mean by
should i mean more people should have
voted for her i'm not suggesting the
election was stolen more people should
have voted for her and we wouldn't be in
this position right now if hillary
clinton had won in 2016 abortion roe v
wade would not be in danger right now
full stop i mean that's it there's no
way around that yeah and we know that
presidents um often get elected well
every time they get elected uh through
the electoral college and so that
benefits republicans at least it has in
recent years and also the senate tends
to skew republican as well because every
state regardless of population gets too
two
senators and so you have this uh
presidency position that's going to skew
right wing you have the senate which is
going to skew right wing and the result
of that is a conservative supreme court
that's also skewing right wing and
that's really not reflective of where
the american public is if you had a
system that was more a portion based on
popularity like if we had the popular
vote for presidents and if we had um
senate seats a portion based on the
population of different states then we
probably wouldn't be in this mess
because we've looked at the polling
people want to preserve roe versus wade
they want to preserve abortion rights in
this country but because we live in this
society and this government that's not
very democratic not very representative
of the american people we're in this
mess to begin with no question about it
so we will be awaiting the decision and
that's not going to be until june
uh we talked yesterday about the
candidacy of dr mehmet oz a regular
purveyor of pseudoscience cures and
quack medicines and the like he's
running as a republican in pennsylvania
or pennsylvania as hold on how does
trump say it pennsylvania
that sounds about right yeah and you got
to mention it's the commonwealth too the
commonwealth of pennsylvania always
worth mentioning
dr oz is uh having his show removed by
some stations i love this tv stations in
philadelphia new york city and cleveland
said yesterday no more dr oz show now
that he is formerly a candidate for u.s
senate
they are saying it's not so much their
personal political views but that they
are compelled by the fcc's equal time
rules to give rival candidates the
ability to request matching air time and
because dr oz has this dr oz show
which is not
like his campaign per se
but that because he is a candidate for
office they would be required to give
john fetterman and you know who knows
whoever else all the same time that dr
oz gets there saying it was it is
completely impractical and so that they
are going to be pulling the show now
there are other stations pat that are
saying
that is not really the spirit of the
equal time laws so we're not going to
take the same approach
which i don't know it would have to be
fought out you know someone would have
to sue someone would have to try to get
access and say listen
dr oz got an hour
i'm running against dr oz i should get
an hour
and then it would be a fight it would
have to be adjudicated legally i don't
know what way it would go it's not
obvious to me that it would be found
that because he has an entertainment
show
his political opponents need the same
amount of time but there's at least some
stations in these three cities saying
we're not going to run the show anymore
and that's of course their prerogative
yeah so that suggests to me that maybe
some of the stations that are not any
longer going to um broadcast his show
maybe they were just looking for a way
out as it was maybe i mean i'd imagine
that dr oz gets good ratings but maybe
now because people are going to
recognize oh this guy's a conservative
and maybe you lose half of your audience
or a good portion of your audience at
least because of that then they'll
figure okay well it's going to be better
for us to broadcast something else
instead this could just be an out we'll
have to wait and see but yeah i mean
this idea that like
it's not a political show and all that
stuff that's mostly true but we know
that he's going to be talking about
kobit a lot i'm sure that he has not
like i actually watched the show but i'm
certain certainly he's talking about
covet and treatments and vaccines and
that sort of thing someone emailed me
and said you know he does at least
advocate mask wearing on kovid in
addition to the fact that he was on
hannity pushing hydroxychloroquine
saying two to three percent death rate
for opening schools is okay you know to
kind of choose your own adventure sort
of situation
yeah i mean i guess the point is that in
any other time you could make the
argument that okay well this is not a
political show he just talks about
medical advice but now we know that the
medical has become the political right
because all these different topics
hydroxychloroquine and ivermectin
and uh the vaccine and everything else
there's a clear political bent to it and
um he's even like sort of hinted at that
in his announcement video that we played
on the show yesterday yeah um talking
about how like some of these medical
experts don't know what they're talking
about and some of our policies when it
comes to coba don't make any sense like
you can already see the overlap there
and so i don't think he can get away
entirely with just saying oh this is a
medical advice show it has nothing to do
with politics or my senate run i don't
think he can do that you also can't get
away with calling it a medical advice
show when you're pushing uh hold on what
was it raspberry ketones and green
coffee bean extract as well as stuffing
lavender in your bed sheets at night to
do so i forget what that was supposed to
do
i do all three of those things but not
for medical reasons for for different
reasons that i can't get into right now
you do it for spiritual reasons not for
medical reasons raspberry ketones are a
link back to uh pat's ancestors if so in
some way and i love the smell of those
things i mean they're just the scents
they make me feel good you know um
it's some people like the smell of cedar
pat prefers raspberry ketones exactly uh
all right so anyway dr oz losing a few
affiliates and we're going to continue
by the way i want to get your take on
this i've been very
uh so i spoke yesterday to
our youtube rep
and i said to him
he's been saying david the midterms are
going to be big in 22. we expect it to
get going like in the spring with a lot
of interest and i was kind of like i
just don't know i don't know
now with the um texas gubernatorial
ron desantis i think is up for
re-election right in 2022 we've got the
senate race with dr oz
lauren beaubert wants trump to do a
rally for her in colorado like this
actually might be one of the most paid
attention to midterms in a long time
that may be so i mean 2018 was a big
deal as well though because it was
democrats first opportunity to go to the
polls after trump got elected and so
there was a lot of attention paid to
that one and there was this idea that
there was going to be a blue wave so you
know maybe it would be on par with that
i don't know if it's going to get any
extra attention certainly republicans
are riled up right now and they do have
a good shot at winning we know that the
virginia gubernatorial race didn't go
our way so that suggests that we may be
in trouble coming up next year as well
but i don't know the spring does sound a
little bit early to me like i would
imagine maybe like summer sounds a
little bit more realistic that's what i
thought but our youtube says we are
predicting that by late april early may
searches for everything election related
will be up that can only be good for
independent media thinking very
selfishly you know well who am i to
disagree with the youtube rep who knows
about this stuff and who has covered
this and and really is in on it
you know
maybe it's going to be maybe we can
split the difference though it'll not be
spring exactly or summer exactly it'll
be like right on the cusp of those two
things like you know like maybe may
maybe memorial that we'll expect
memorial day will be the official start
of the i expect trump to do a memorial
day rally for someone running in 2022
that'll be the official start i guess is
my my prediction
yeah but maybe not ron desantis though
he can't give him too much clout no he
wants to make ron fight on his own so
that way he doesn't have to worry about
running against him in 2024. i'm looking
forward to that battle as well trump
versus desantis just on rhetoric uh okay
thanks everybody we'll be back tomorrow
with a new show and a new bonus show and
we're we're here guys we're here it's
december and we've got a lot going on